hey hows it going bros my name is Pewdiepieeeeeeee
welcome back to the beautiful Caribbean I'm here, Nate, with my brother Sam
We just found the treasure
we just found the place
but of course we gotta find a shortcut *Of course, why not?*
that's cool, I don't really care; it's whatever
we're playing this game every single day util we finish it for like an hour
so check out part one if you're new, otherwise let's enjoy this hour together
Look at this fucking beautiful view man
So we came from that tower, followed some fucking arrows
How dumb is that? Look at that, We could've just seen that first and be like 'aye'
I wonder if you replay the game, you could just skip that shit
This is the kind of game i would love to replay, just for the stuff
Parts, I kinda wish that there were more of the stuff, shit?
*CC person forgets to type more, walks away and drops microphone*